yeah no
velcro how are we gonna get out of this
one
we will find hope
than impossible
well at least I won't die alone well
that's just typical hi I'm max ml from
FX guide.com for wired for 50 years fans
have enjoyed the Star Trek universe and
a near-constant in all that time has
been the cruise home in space on the
starship USS Enterprise NCC one 7:01 of
course the enterprise has not always
actually been that well treated and we
count about nine that have appeared on
the screen the visual effects in the new
film are headed by double negative in
London who did a lot of the exterior
work that you see they were helped out
by atomic fiction who did about 350
shots and many of those were building
out the inside of the enterprise the job
of making the enterprise is an
interesting one the team wanted to be
faithful to the history of the franchise
but they're also operating in an
environment where they absolutely knew
the fans would be pulling apart every
detail Ryan Todd hope and Kevin Bailey
supervise the work of building about
much of the interior of the ship which
included that new area such as the
manual release room and the new
engineering spaces the previous
engineering room in the film into
darkness having actually been shot in a
real brewery as the ship would be ripped
apart and we'd see inside it in
graphical new ways the team had to work
out all the internal logic and lay out
the construction where everything went
there are thousands of things including
thousands of screens in front of almost
every crew member an enormous amount of
work goes into making a believable
working enterprise for example every one
of those screens needs to be filled with
something that kind of makes sense
though of course it's completely made up
it needs to have a logic that is
understandable well not being
distracting the audience needs to see
these screens and believe that they're
of that world even though they have no
idea what they do display graphics gets
almost no credit in feature films but
it's actually a really important area
and there's an entire design team
responsible for doing them the lead
designer on beyond was Gladys Tong of G
created productions in Vancouver she
heads up an on-set playback and design
team that produces all of those graphics
from the practical archive screens
to the nebula holograms of the team walk
around these are all designed by G
creative and then handed over to
companies like atomic fiction as still
flat art and they then animate them and
bring them to life the secret in making
environments in the enterprise or just
graphics on a prop is to respect the
culture in a sense these are all
historical items reflecting both the
fictional and filmic Federation ancestry
in the last 50 years there's a kind of a
DNA and the science and engineering has
to respect that sense and the world that
inhabits of course this all starts with
the concept art that works out the looks
that the team built from so much of the
enterprise's of course digital or done
with digital set extension but the work
doesn't stop there in fact there's a lot
of character work as well this is where
the frontier when the aliens attack and
board the enterprise almost all the
aliens apart from Crowell himself are in
fact CG characters there were stuntmen
filmed on set to give eyelines but then
atomic fiction digitally replaced all
those actors with fully CG aliens
now this is all happening while the
principal plate photography is being
filmed on giant motion control multi
axis gimbals so that said extension
which was already quite hard has made
even more difficult by adding in a large
number of digital characters to the
scenes well it's great to see the
enterprise back on screen in this 13th
Star Trek feature film Star Trek beyond
don't forget please subscribe for more
behind the scenes action I'm Mike Zimmer
for wide